welcome back so a middle school teacher
in Houston is charged with human
smuggling after allegedly transporting
illegal immigrants from across the U.S
Mexico border officials say 26 year old
Brandon Gracia was initially contacted
through social media and took the
opportunity to make some quick cash it's
just one of the latest instances of
cartel and Smugglers recruiting
Americans online joining me now to
explain former acting ice director Tom
Holm and Tom
um I I've never seen this criminal
Enterprise so in Bolden what is
happening I mean they're recruiting
Grandma's kids the Crips and bloods I
mean it's they're surging right now
no and I didn't see it when I was an
agent this is this is new right the
Houston social media platforms let me
tell you why because the cartels are so
busy they're moving so many people
during a historic crisis they need to
contract to work out so look why not
hire a high school kid to transport
somebody within the United States which
is a felony they'll pay him a few
thousand bucks that way the cartel stays
out of jail and the kids at risk but
here's the here's the most dangerous
part of this Lawrence who are they
moving there's two different types of
people coming across the border those
who pay a certain amount to come across
the board and turn themselves in those
who pay more money to get away why do
they want to get away why don't they
cross the border turn themselves into
border patrol get released get a plane
ticket a government expense flown to the
city their choice and given work
authorization why would they not take
advantage of that program they want to
get away why because they don't want to
be fingerprinted so the people that are
transporting are the gotaways these are
gang members these are criminals these
may be known suspect to terrorists
they're probably carrying Fentanyl and
the worst of it is they probably victims
of trafficking which these drivers are
going to deliver these people women to
be forcing a prostitution children to be
forced in the labor this is a terrible
thing happening and they need to open
their eyes they are they're doing
nothing but helping the cartels and
voting the cartels the more people they
successfully move in the United States
the more people are going to keep coming
Tom what are the agents telling you that
are on the ground dealing with this on a
day-to-day basis with no support from
the administration zero
look they got no morale there's zero
morale they lost total confidence in the
uh Secretary of Homeland Security at
under majorcus and they lost confidence
in president's United States why because
both the secretary and the president has
abandoned them the secretary to this day
has been submitted there's a crisis and
these men and women are working 24 7 the
worst numbers we've ever seen in their
career and while they're in their
processing these family groups they're
looking up at the TV seeing the
secretary on national TV saying there's
no crisis we got this under control
illegal alien numbers are going down
they only use the numbers that went down
the last two months because they're
pushing them to a Port of Entry they're
making illegal immigration legal which
only further infuriates the men and
women the border patrol who just want to
Simply do their job to secure the border
which saves lives yeah you still got
border agents that are on desk Duty over
a fake whipping Scandal that never
happened and they knew it
um Tom Holman thanks so much brother hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else